[Music]
[Applause]
it's almost time for paris hilton and
her fiance carter rheem to say i do
so naturally her loved ones are
celebrating her with a bridal shower fit
for an heiress
the cooking with paris star enjoyed a
lavish alice in wonderland themed bridal
shower over the weekend with her mom
kathy hilton her aunt kyle richards and
a few familiar faces from the real
housewives of beverly hills including
garcelle bouvier dorie kemsley and
crystal kung minkoff
kyle shared several snaps from the day
on instagram including two with her
sister and mama the bride and a selfie
with her castmates this is just a day in
the life of you know garcelle also
posted a couple pics from the event
including two with the bride to be who
was dressed in a white lace dress with
puffed sleeves she captioned the post
quote congratulations paris hilton your
bridal shower was just as fabulous as
you are hashtag paris in love and she
was not kidding as guests entered the
party they were greeted by the mad
hatter who was seated by the front door
among giant roses inside the soiree
there were stunning paris and
wonderland-themed cookies and a cake
featuring a giant teapot the house was
decorated with giant teacups filled with
roses and just check that out a
champagne vending machine
also in attendance were a few of the
heiress's famous friends like caroline
de moray rachel zoe nicole english and
gigi gorgeous i was so excited but this
was hardly the first party to celebrate
the love birds paris and carter held
their joint bachelor and bachelorette
party in las vegas last weekend the 40
year old dj documented the epic party on
instagram sharing photos from a party
bus poolside and inside some of vegas's
biggest nightclubs can you give us any
updates on wedding news with you and mr
carter yes i'm so excited we've been
shooting my new show with peacock called
paris in love just last month paris
dished on her upcoming nuptials during a
chat with e.t and revealed that she had
officially said i do to the dress of her
dreams
a lot of planning going into it picking
up my wedding dress and
it's going to be soon in the next few
months really very soon that we nailed
down the dress just yet here
yes but it's a surprise the two got
engaged in february after a year of
dating paris announced their engagement
just after valentine's day on her 40th
birthday writing on instagram in part
quote when you find your soul mate you
don't just know it you feel it there's
no one i'd rather spend forever with
here's to love the forever kind
[Music]
you